[Music]
and and honestly you know on that note
this this is why movies and media and
video games
are so damaging yeah they robbed of
these opportunities that you could be
out blessing other people what could you
have done where could you have gone
what what you know rescue operations
could you have gone on to save Humanity
you know it's like yeah hey everybody
Welcome to LED live
yeah
I'm with my brother Brock Meyer welcome
to show Brock thank you it's good to be
here I'm glad to have you on again I'm
inspired by what this guy's doing
um and I think you'll you'll you'll
you'll appreciate these stories because
um I think you know you see the world
having problems and it's like I want to
help but I don't know where to help so
if you're thinking that this show is for
you tell us a little bit about yourself
Brock yeah you know it's it's really
amazing we live in these incredible
times where we can discern the weather
you know we've got all these amazing
channels even on YouTube where you can
follow the weather to a t right I know
exactly where this storm's gonna hit the
destruction's gonna happen and yet and
yet we really don't understand the times
in which we live and that's something
that Jesus says you know in Matthew 16
you know he says you can discern the
weather you can know that it's going to
be a good day or a bad day based on just
looking at the sunset or the sunrise and
yet you don't even know the signs of the
times in which you live and so Matthew
24 I mean when you look at Matthew 24
man the world is falling apart right
before Jesus comes and we see just a
whole list of things and number one
thing that Jesus says is beware that no
man deceives you and so I I mean I know
like your whole Ministry and show is is
built around this fact like don't let
anything or anyone deceive you and yet
that's the biggest problem that we see
in the world today is that is that the
information that we're getting about not
just um you know movies and media but
even just in in general in life the news
channels yeah you can't trust any of
them you can't and it's and it's with
the manipulation of video I mean now you
can't even trust your eyeballs I mean
it's just getting absolutely insane so
how do you where do you where do you
find truth how do you know what what is
true I think the book that you're
holding in your hands really is the
answer to all of these problems that we
have in our world today absolutely so
you know we're reading out of Matthew 24
Wars rumors of wars pestilence disease
famine and all of these things are
really just the beginning of problems
that we're going to see before the
second coming of Christ I mean let alone
even just the claims of people claiming
to be Christ yep which should be
exciting I mean when we see these kind
of things ramping up we obviously in our
day and age we've seen kind of a lot of
disasters and a lot of like Wars it
seems like and it seems like they're
getting more frequent hard to say is it
just because we have social media and we
can share them quicker or are these
things actually transpiring more and
more frequent yeah I mean that's a great
question and I think it definitely
warrants an investigation into what is
the truth but what's even more
fascinating to me is that the Bible says
because iniquity abounds the love of
many is going to wax cold so you see
this like in the movies the media you
know as things are just absolutely
climbing in terms of debauchery then
there's this love for Humanity that that
is extinguished as a result and we
definitely see this like you know people
don't care care about people anymore
like you know horrible things will
happen right in front they'll even get
their cell phone out and film it right
but yet they won't step in and stop it
right you know and this is just the
world that we live in now and it's
totally exactly what the Bible says is
that the hearts of men are gonna be
failing them for fear and and waxing
cold like that basic love for Humanity
like love for your neighbor like how you
know if your neighbor's house is on fire
would you actually do something about it
you know or would you just stand there
and get your phone out and film it on
YouTube and watch it burn
really appreciate about your ministry um
Gideon rescue Ministry you guys will
hear a little bit more about this uh
this ministry but it is a really neat
organization that centers around helping
people in disasters War zones you name
it you guys are are literally there to
just lend a hand that's amazing to me
yeah yeah in fact the beginning of this
year we had an opportunity to go to
Ukraine and I know Ukraine is big in the
news because it's it's just a real
prominent you know piece of you know
stuff that's happening around us right
now but
um it was really amazing what Drew us to
Ukraine actually was the opportunity to
hand people
some hope-filled literature amen and so
that's what actually got our team off
the ground was that we knew in the
western part of Ukraine there was
actually a church that had a whole
stockpile of literature in the Ukrainian
language and there was 50 000 plus
refugees pouring through the train
station every day and so we thought well
what an opportunity what a platform
right even if because we're not soldiers
like we we're not we're not
International Aid workers like we don't
have some big funding you know behind us
but we thought what could we do to give
somebody
um you know hope and that was something
that would that we felt was
something we could jump on you have a
saying that I always hear you say um you
can live x amount of time without
breathing what is that saying yeah I
mean you can you can go weeks without
food you know days without water you can
hold your breath for a few minutes you
know but the moment you give up hope
it's done yeah so in the hierarchy of
needs I think this is a challenge that
we have is that we don't recognize that
the greatest need actually is Hope
we put we relegate that kind of lower
it's like we need food shelter safety
all those things and those are important
but actually what's the highest need is
is Hope and it makes sense that there's
got to be something better than this I
mean there's you know you're seeing your
country torn apart in front of you
you're seeing you know lands being
confiscated or houses being destroyed
and it's like this can't be it like that
that would be sad to me if if you really
only had that mindset when you're done
you're done it's all over there's got to
be something to look forward to and then
also to understand that you know what
there's a war going on and we're caught
in between that that Cosmic war and this
is a result of sin and and it playing
out on on human form one thing I really
actually love about the disaster Zone
and I know that kind of sounds like
an oxymoron How Could You Love a
disaster Zone where there's death and
destruction those types of things but
what's amazing is that when we step into
these disastrones to help someone else
to help the neighbor it's like God gives
us a mini instruction or mini lesson in
what it means to trust him
right when the World falls apart how do
you trust him and I think that at the
end of the day that's one of the most
valuable lessons that I would
communicate to anybody is that hard
times have already come to a lot of
people but there's even harder times
that are coming in the near future yeah
and so it it is that at the basic
Foundation it's all about how do you
trust God when everything's falling
apart when there are no systems that you
can rely on anymore you can't pick up
the phone and dial 9-1-1 who's going to
be there to help you yeah and God
promises in his word that he's going to
walk with you even through the valley of
the shadow of death and we see this time
and time again
um and in fact when we went to Ukraine
that was one thing that we knew not only
in in helping give people hope biblical
hope but we also recognize that they
needed something tangible something
physical and so I had a guy that had
called
um
um just saying hey we've got some
tourniquets we're going to donate to you
and we're going to send them over there
to Ukraine and if you can take them in
we would love it and we're awesome cool
I'll drop ship them to Dallas Texas I'd
live right above Dallas and
um
he called me maybe a day before we were
leaving and he said I'm so sorry like I
don't have any tourniquets to send you
oh no
and it was like okay it's okay like
God's got this worked out right like
we're going over there if God needs
tourniquets he can supply the
tourniquets right and so as I was
walking off the plane in Warsaw um it
was really amazing uh there was this
this these gentlemen that I met and um
they had suitcases with them and they
were talking about all these supplies
they were trying to send into Ukraine
from Warsaw and they themselves didn't
want to go and they said well are you
going to Ukraine we said yeah we're
headed over there you know for this
mission to give people hope they said oh
perfect can we give you all of our
supplies of course you know so notice
how he's not even shocked by this
anymore like like this is just something
that that Brock has experienced over and
over and over again going to these these
kind of events like yeah God's got this
figured out yeah it's called just in
time uh shipping I got it does this
right just in time management and and so
as we walk off the plane here we open up
these suitcases and guess what was
inside these suitcase of course bunch of
tourniquets tourniquets like stock full
hundreds of tourniquets so that was how
the trip started like for me and I
actually wasn't the first wave there was
we had actually sent multiple waves at
this point team members going over there
giving out literature wow in the train
station singing songs and playing music
for people in the train station it was
amazing we don't have time to cover all
the amazing things that that I I'm
curious though did you have any
opposition like people coming to you you
can't sing in here you can't do this I
mean we're people like no the guy the
guy actually at the train station was
amazing the guy at the train station
wasn't even a Christian of any type he
was a total atheist and he was studying
music at the at the University in leviv
and he said you know what
I I want to do something about this
horrible situation all these refugees
pouring out most of women and children
75 to 80 of all the refugees are women
and children how can I do something for
these these people so he went to his
university and he grabbed a piano which
you know how hard it is to move a piano
like full upright piano put it on a
truck took it over to the train station
and he just sits down and he's playing
like like Disney songs only songs he
knows right yeah right but he's just
trying to play music to try to like
encourage people and Inspire him you
know yeah so when our team came there
they're like hey can you play some hymns
and he was like I don't know if I know
any hymns and so they started singing a
few to him and he was really good with
his ear and also he's playing Amazing
Grace that's awesome and it was amazing
all these people crowding around
listening to just music beautiful
blessing them for the little moment that
they walk by yeah just giving them a
little bit of assurance and a little bit
of hope you know yeah it's it's not as
difficult as we think like sometimes we
think in our mind the threshold to be
involved is so high yeah and it's like
well I need all this organization and
you need all these like different things
to come together before before we can do
this not just go over there and I'm
going to go pick a train station and
sing in it right right
and a lot of people think like well you
know I I don't work for the Red Cross
you know I don't work for you know all
these big organizations Samaritan's
Purse or any of these other big groups
you know but you don't have to yeah you
know and and the reality is is that you
know the U.N they're not going to bring
a piano and set it and train station
start playing for people right no way
it's just it's not even on their radar
right so so if if you if you have the
ability to have some creativity and let
God work with that he'll give you
platforms that the world doesn't even
have yeah to reach people give them hope
the secret sauce is how can I bless
somebody else right yeah right so you
know a lot of what we did was real
humble work in Ukraine you know I don't
think anybody would just sign up
necessarily to go over there and pass
out pamphlets yeah you know in the midst
of a war yeah but but it was amazing
because these tracks that had in fact by
the time these tracks arrived we didn't
even know that they were coming
and all of a sudden somebody's like hey
we got a donation we want somebody
wanted to print a million tracks there
in Poland and they're like can you get
can your team distribute a million
tracks and it was like well man we'll
try yeah I mean what's beautiful about
this is like okay we don't have
literature we don't even have like
supplies and stuff like that you start
this process you put your foot in the
Jordan and God's like oh you need a
million pieces of literature to go hand
out here you go go and give this stuff
out right that's amazing and it was so
it was so neat the titles that we had
were perfect titles for situation it was
four titles it was does God care if I'm
hurting the power of prayer
um what happens when you die and Jesus
is coming again beautiful so these are
these are all topics that people are
worried about right like as they're
fleeing from Ukraine they're thinking
does God care if I'm hurting uh does
prayer really work right you know my
husband who's left behind is probably
going to die so what's going to happen
to him and in all of this mess
is there a solution is Jesus coming
again so so that's why we see such a
power in the printed yeah you know word
and everywhere we go we try to leave
people with something tangible so they
can hang on to it they can research it
later and go back to their Bibles they
can study these topics out and give them
hope yep and and the pamphlet is such a
neat neat thing because it folds up so
small I mean you can carry hundreds of
them in your pocket and and you're
giving somebody just a little piece of
information you know they don't have to
carry a book you're not giving them
something that's like super uber
intimidating you're standing around in
line you can read it you know yeah and
that that's exactly what happened so
many people had time to read these
things that we were able to give out and
and the faces man people are so excited
like when you give them something
they're just like you know in the
stories that say you came all the way
from America for this moment here to
give me this like oh no please give me
like five more packs I want to give them
to my friends and my family and so
people are so appreciative so excited
about this you know for all the
naysayers out there that are like hey
this is a [__] Mission you shouldn't
do this you know it's like this is what
motivates us is when we run into these
guys in the streets who are just so
excited about what it is that we're
doing
um man it's a blessing right right
um so and even for the kids you know uh
one of our one of our teamers actually
brought his 11 year old son that's
awesome which a lot of people were like
whoa like what are you doing
your own son to a war zone you know and
every night the the Airaid Sirens go
would go off and we'd have some rocket
attacks that would hit the airport that
were a couple miles away and a radio
station in town so I mean there's real
danger for sure but but what was amazing
is when people saw like you brought your
son
like you brought your son like your most
prized possession right and you're
willing to risk the life of your son to
give me a piece of paper oh my goodness
what's on this piece of paper that
you're willing to risk your life for
right right so like that that that is so
inspiring to people and they want to
know all about it and so when you see a
kid handing out stuff in the streets
people are interested that's cool and uh
so and a lot of these things too we're
we're just these little pictures that we
would send this little girl she's
holding this this picture of this cross
and I think in Ukrainian it says you
know Jesus loves you it just nothing
nothing more complex than that but the
smile on her face and she's so excited
like the hope that that you see people
gain from just that small interaction is
priceless like you could spend Millions
upon millions of dollars and you would
not achieve the same effect as if
somebody themselves took the initiative
to go and give somebody some hope I
think it's just that simple somebody
else cares and even speaks more when
somebody from the other side of the
world is like wow you you you spent
money flying here when everybody else is
exiting out of this place you ran to
this place and you care enough to to
just give me a piece of paper like I I
mean that speaks volumes and I and I
think like yeah we don't we don't put
enough
um emphasis on the value of of sharing
the gospel in a time like this right
you know a lot of people actually
um you know we get the accusation times
that that we focus too much on the Hope
Focus too much on the spiritual side of
things but it's because we see such a
hunger and people are so broken and
they're just needing encouragement I
mean we can show you video after video
and store after Story people just
breaking down in tears saying you know
you're here you're praying with me I
know God is real because you're here in
this moment but um God also gives us
practical ways you know to share it's
not just it's not just the spiritual it
is the Practical so we we actually
taught you know families and children
and kids like what to do in times of
emergency you know like if if you're
bleeding how to stop that bleeding and
God led us to some pretty unique
opportunities
um you know where they're actually
teaching people
um how to save life not just take life
but but it's such a weird world like
this this video here that I have for you
you can see that they're showing here uh
these women
um how to load a Kalashnikov you know
and how to throw grenade and you have to
realize that that these are the Home
Defense so this is this is these are not
regular soldiers this is the last
possible defense like if if the soldiers
lose the front lines then then it's the
women and your girlfriend and the kids
back home that are going to be picking
up weapons and defending their their
home and they're and they're teaching
these ladies how to hold a gun and how
to fire a gun and how it won't knock
them off their balance because they've
never they've never held a weapon
they've never fired a weapon right and
so the learning curve is steep you know
and and what what broke my heart was as
you're watching these young ladies you
know
um being instructed in how to use a
weapon for Destruction and you realize
like if these if these girls ever see
combat
they won't stand a chance right like
five minutes right especially against
somebody that's trained right yeah
the absolute Insanity of it you know is
just war is is so evil you know it and
and and these poor people caught in the
middle of this they don't understand the
greater conflict that's happening right
so then so then in that instance it's
like okay even if I was the most trained
most amazing Special Forces Soldier and
had all this knowledge to impart to them
what would be the most important thing
that they should receive
how to pull the trigger hmm
um or or how to save life or or what's
happening in the greater context of a
great conversation like where are we
headed right like like in the context of
this world what does Ukraine have
anything to do with the battle between
good and evil right
right and that is actually most
important yeah you know so so that
became our mission is that every class
we didn't touch anything to do with the
weapons because we're not soldiers but
but they asked us they actually the
civil defense asked us they said we're
teaching all these ladies and civilians
how to shoot weapons and throw grenades
and load bullets I have another video
here you mean you can see this guy I
mean like do you this guy looks like he
belongs you know at the controller store
yeah or at a record store but at the
controls right playing Call of Duty
right you know he's got his headphones
you know what I mean but here he is
actually loading the real physical
bullets into a magazine he's never done
it before like you know if bombs are
exploding and shells are going off next
to him and bullets are whizzing past his
head do you think he's going to remember
any of this if you've never done this
before I mean I could I could see why
yeah like they want to know a little bit
about how to do this but right yeah so
so then it becomes like well what
opportunity we have to reach somebody
like this yeah
like what is he what is he longing for
yeah you know and so after every class
we were we were actually asked to do
just the medical proportion of just how
to how to basically patch up wounds you
know like if you're if you're getting
shot at you know Under Fire you know how
do you put on a tourniquet so here they
are they're teaching these ladies you
know 70 of all the students are girls
you know young girls 20 to 30 years old
and they're teaching them how to put on
a tourniquet real quick and and and what
that looks like under that's why they're
laying down like if they're under Fire
like how would they apply that
tourniquet so they could try to save
their life but keep their own life and
and and you realize just the absolute
futile
um desperation and Desperation of it you
know and and even just applying
tourniquets
um you know where you're just
instructing like how do you put on this
turning how do you wrap how do you stop
bleeding and and realize that these
people had had absolutely no medical
training whatsoever you know I've spent
years training you know how to how to
patch holes and and and and try to save
somebody's life in a traumatic situation
and these people are getting a crash
course in in in one hour right two hours
yeah you know wrap this around yeah tie
it off move on right so
um it was it was absolutely
heartbreaking
um and you know what was interesting
about it is that
I had I had an individual come up to me
after the class
and um he said
he said this is crazy
this is absolutely crazy
I think the gravity of it was settling
in on him you know he's like I'm a
civilian he's like I know nothing about
war it's I don't even know how to fire a
gun he said we're not gonna they'll cut
us down out there
and I said well I said that is true
you're up against Insanity I said but
you can remember that no matter how hard
it gets I want you to remember this no
matter how hard it gets how crazy it
gets out there you have one weapon
that will never fail you yeah and he was
like what's that I was like it's prayer
yeah you can always drop to your knees
and pray and God will hear your prayer
yeah and and he looked at me with an
absolute sense of of of hopelessness
because he said well that's fine for you
because you believe he's like I don't
believe anything hmm it's like I'm an
atheist and he has nothing
and and it hit me like man I was it was
hard to finish that class like teaching
you know those skills and everything and
in the background is Playing Lord like
how do we how do we reach somebody like
that right because that's what he needs
he needs hope like you know they say
there's no atheists in foxholes it's
true like when when the bombs are going
off man you're on your knees like if
there is a God Lord you're out there you
gotta save me you know and so at the end
we just made this this appeal right you
know like God would send us all the way
from middle of nowhere America to
Ukraine
for this moment in time not just to
teach you how to put on a tourniquet
yeah but to give you hope yeah right and
a future like Jesus is coming again wars
and rumors of wars this is what's
happening in the landscape around us but
the context for why that's happening
yeah I think when somebody's presented
with a a s a serious situation like that
you really begin to filter through
what's important in life like like you
he's not thinking about his car he's not
thinking about his house he's not
thinking about anything you know what I
mean it's like what's really important
and at that moment that heart window can
open
and you can preach the gospel right
exactly exactly so man I we laid it on
thick and at the end I I came up to that
guy he apologized to me said I'm so
sorry I said I didn't realize that
you're a Christian and he's like I
didn't mean to offend you by making the
comment that I made and I said man you
haven't offended me I was like it's not
a matter of it's not a matter of if
you're going to consider these things
it's a matter of when you're going to
get to a point in life where you're not
going to have any answers or Solutions
or how to get out of the situation so
that's the moment you're going to
remember this conversation
and and the things that we've taught you
and and instructing and telling you like
you've always had you always have prayer
as an option I said that's when it's
going to matter and he was in tears he
was just like thank you so much for
coming all the way from from where you
came just to be here in this moment like
you know recognizing that man somebody
cares for him right even if we're the
totally two different world views right
somebody I I would love it man like if
if my hometown is being attacked yeah
and some atheist came from Ukraine yeah
you know it was like man I'm here for
you I want to help you I don't believe
in God but I'm here for you right you
know what I mean like not touch me you
know I'd be like man like you you risked
yourself to come here to be with me in
my misery right it's true it is true why
do you why do you always have that
Christians that end up doing those kind
of things you know it's like because
they love the most often yes is the
Christians yeah yeah yeah but but that's
the platform you're exactly right like
it it it it it opens it's what we call
the spiritual golden hour
this is why we go back to time time
again is because there's a window right
like from the time that an event occurs
whether it be a natural disaster or
death in the family a financial crisis
you name it the clock is ticking right
and you have moments in which to reach
someone
and and it's in that moment that if
rightly placed a conversation a piece of
literature
a song
oh man people's hearts open they just
melt because they're ready oh you know
it's like they they need they need that
encouragement you know they need that
that hug like does God give hugs today
oh absolutely he wants to give hugs to
his people yeah like as we work and we
live for God God can use us
and we can we can give that to someone
else yeah that's beautiful your ministry
it really has such a neat facet to it
because you are a company of some
trained you know medical personnel but
then also you've got just random people
that will show up no skills whatsoever
and and they're having a wonderful time
you know working with with people and
it's transforming their hearts yeah you
know yeah there's no shortage to what
God can do with one who's just willing
yep that's it yep just got to be willing
open the Heart Lord with me like we were
talking about um um you know the
tornadoes that happened uh about a year
ago this time December a year ago and um
in in Kentucky and we had that guy who
was literally playing video games on his
couch right he's playing video games on
Call of Duty or whatever he's playing
right you know and the Holy Spirit Taps
him on the shoulder and says you need to
get up off that couch you need to go
down to Kentucky and help those people
and he listened like he set his
controller down got up had no idea where
he was going what his plan was drove
down there and God attaches them to our
team wow and he has a whole
transformative experience where he gives
his heart to Jesus because of what he
experiences in the disaster Zone helping
someone else wow so was it more of a
blessing to him absolutely like it's
more blessed to give than receive yeah
and so so we see this all the time and
it's actually in our ministry we
recognize that the power of training
um
everybody yeah like there there is no
there is no barrier for anybody to be
involved and so even like you know this
this next picture that's up here you
know here we are in in um uh this is
Montana actually we had a whole bunch of
families that said hey will you come up
and we do training with us and a
collective group of families at the
little church and they're like please
come up with six families that want to
do training and Disaster Response so we
did the same thing we did in Ukraine we
did it for these guys in Montana and the
kids loved it like the kids were all a
part of it they were all teaching them
how to jump in the water how to save
each other how to you know
um tie knots all those different things
and those practical things are how you
engage
our young people and our families into
into service for others because the
family like the family unit's so
important right it's not just the
individual we we see there's so much
power in a family unit right it was
Abraham's family that was a witness
right his whole household was a witness
right wherever he went like wherever
whatever he did God blessed him and all
the nations were like hey man like
there's something different about
Abraham and his family it's no different
today like when you have a family that's
actually on fire for God people take
note of that they're like wow like look
at these kids look at these parents like
it's a real beautiful thing to see so
it's something we've really tried to do
in our training too
um no shortage though of opportunity to
go and serve no shortage like we could
be busy every month of the year all year
long right all across the globe you know
right anywhere and it's only going to
get busier if we understand what the
Bible is telling us exactly it's going
to get worse and this is what we're
seeing every disaster we're going to
actually is getting bigger in scope
bigger in scale the more people that
it's affected thankfully we haven't seen
the death toll rising at the same
intensity of these disasters I think we
will I think I think we're coming to a
point where it's not just going to be
you know in this last snowstorm that
rolled through this this whole area and
there were like 58 people lost their
lives and that's a lot but there's going
to come a point where disaster is going
to happen earthquakes right specifically
some of these bigger large
hundreds of thousands of people gone you
know imagine the heartache you know how
many people have lost family or loved
ones in that opportunity they just need
a hug they need somebody to tell them
that God's Not Forgotten right right so
here we are in Kentucky just some images
from Kentucky here and um
you know it's amazing those are actually
steel i-beams from a bridge just bent
like you know like they're a coat hanger
wow you know and and and just the rubble
that was it was everywhere and this is a
real blessing we actually got to use our
search and rescue dogs for the first
time and so our search and rescue dogs
here
um were combing through the rubble but
even then it's just it's such a a a
small effort you know in in the scope of
what's happening in in these areas
um but the dogs give us an incredible
um access into these areas because
people are like oh you have certain
rescue dogs like oh yes we need your
help like you know these communities
over here haven't even been searched
like these debris piles haven't even
been searched so we spent quite a bit of
time searching looking in these in these
places with some of the top teams from
around the nation actually
um and it was a blessing where you can
see that promise where if you're
faithful to the calling that God gives
you he'll make you the head and not the
tail
in and so we've experienced that we've
seen that in some of the the search and
rescue operations and things that we've
done and so is there a practical thread
to what we do yeah like the dogs are an
incredible asset and and they're a
blessing when used when they're
searching for either victims that are
alive or even victims who have who have
died in the disaster they're an
incredible asset that can be used for an
incredible amount of good but
there's so much that can be done in just
the simple form like you don't have to
be a dog handler you have to spend years
in training for that you know you don't
have to be certified in all these
different things that some of our
handlers are can you can you pray with
someone
mm-hmm you know I had I had a we our
team pilot he called me
um actually I just remember this he
called me uh this fall and he said
he said
I have a a friend here who just lost his
daughter in the woods hmm and he said uh
she's been gone for six hours we have it
located or don't know where she's at I
know you guys have dogs can I send my
plane or can I send another plane to
pick you up we'll we'll bring you here
and and get you on the on the mission
looking for this little girl that's
missing and I said absolutely like sure
like I'll get off the phone and I was
just getting ready to hang up and I was
impressed pray with him and so I just
told him I said hold on so one time
before we go I said let's pray about
this so we start praying and I just said
Lord I know you know where this little
girl's at like you can find this little
girl and you don't even need us right
like you don't need the fancy dogs and
all this thing and playing to come pick
us up and all this whole mission to
unfold you can find this little girl and
so we just asked like in Jesus name find
this little girl hung up the phone I I'm
calling my team trying to activate our
dog handles like hey get your get your
gear get your dogs get ready they're
sending a plane pick you guys up and he
calls me back maybe five minutes later
and he's laughing on the other end of
the phone he says you'll never guess
what happened
I still have he said they found the
little girl oh wow and it was such it
was such a testimony to him right
because he's he's a bit of a soft
agnostic so he doesn't really fully like
believe these promises that are in God's
word so when he's like Man Prayer works
yeah he's like that was amazing he's
like prayer works like it just blew his
mind you know that prayer prayer could
be used in a practical way right yeah
you don't even have to put boots on the
ground right right right you know put
Faith in that God is really the
orchestrator of all of this and you know
we can have the greatest tools or
technology or you know anything but it's
like yeah you you have to first
recognize okay God this is this is your
world and you know help me out in this
situation yeah and always bringing him
into the equation you know right yeah we
and God has taught us so many lessons in
the power of prayer and you know in the
power of His word too you know we had
another opportunity where um this year
we had you know we're having tornadoes
in very uncharacteristic times of this
of the year you know we don't don't
typically see tornadoes in November we
don't see them in December we don't see
them in January and yet this is now The
New Normal right it's like tornado and
not just in Oklahoma where yeah
it's like all throughout the United
States you know even even across the
globe and other places where you've
never even heard tornadoes like in
Europe you know they they're having
tornadoes as well and um and so we
actually had an opportunity to go to
um a little tiny town in Texas Paris
Texas and
um it just wiped out with a little
tornado that came through that area
wasn't wasn't significantly huge in
terms of loss of life but significant
damage and you know as you're looking at
some of these images here you could you
could see just the destruction you know
like the these wind speeds that come
through and just level a house like
these are like fully you know framed
Foundation you know solid structures
that you know don't even stand
um you know the test of of these winds
but what's so amazing is in each one of
these this little neighborhood we ended
up in in each one of these houses was a
testimony of how each family had
survived well I know it's amazing to me
when you see the damage and you go how
is this not more people die yeah like
how are they all survivors in this thing
you know like I firmly believe it
because of the struggle between good and
evil because the devil is trying to
destroy as many people as possible and
God is trying to save that's what you
see in these storms is you see the devil
in his anger trying to take out as many
people and the angels of God are
shielding people saying nope you can't
have this family yet like they they need
they need to know something more about
my character and who I am right so God
is literally saving people and in this
neighborhood it was incredible in the in
that first image that I showed
a house that was nearly leveled right
the the way that person survived is that
their their sibling who's their brother
called him and said hey get out of the
house now there's something coming
towards you get out of the house now
they got in the car they left their
house level not not a room in the house
left right and then and then some of the
other places like we talked to this
young kid they literally chose a closet
in one of the rooms and they all huddled
in this closet and every other room in
the house was totally destroyed and like
debris but the closet they were in
not touched isn't that amazing then it's
one of those flimsy closet doors you
know like nothing nothing holding
anything back you know and and then at
the last house that went to this is what
was incredible one of the last houses
that we went to there
um oh actually here we played some music
too talking about music before we moved
to the next one
um and it was so amazing when when you
play music like this is Robbie he brings
his whole cello and and we have a guitar
and we're singing Amazing Grace and
people are just blown away they're like
you brought your cello to a disaster
Zone yeah you know it doesn't make sense
but when they hear somebody playing
Amazing Grace yeah then something Clicks
in their mind they know that they've
been spared from the storm only by God's
Amazing Grace yeah amen amen so so it is
such a powerful opportunity to to work
with people and witness people and
actually you need a whole Orchestra to
travel with you yeah I mean how amazing
would that be right you show up and it's
like the disaster vehicle and you know
it's like a big MOG vehicle or whatever
like that and out the back people are
just playing music yeah that would
Garden some attention there yeah of
course of course it's actually a
Biblical principle because Jehoshaphat
put the choir before the Army yep right
yeah like could music actually be a
practical weapon yeah that could turn
the tide of battle Yeah and the answer
is yes in history it's actually been
used that way yeah so that's why they
play drums music
try to pump people up you know yeah it's
so powerful
um but here we are in this house and I
don't know if the audio is up on this
one yeah but
what you can what you can find here
this house is destroyed right like half
of this house is gone and the framers
who built the house
psalm 91.
free shall give his angels charge over
thee
that's awesome and then Deuteronomy 28 6
right blessed shall you be when you come
in and bless it until you be when you go
out
and then they even had another one up
here too
as for me and my house we will serve the
Lord right
some Joshua
Joshua 24 24 15. so just just amazing
like like it's like is there power in
God's word you know and and and when the
framers built all of these houses in
this neighborhood this is what's amazing
this is one of the hardest hit
neighborhoods in this little tiny Town
most these houses are totally wiped out
right
and and in this neighborhood every
single house that was constructed
the framers wrote Bible verses on all
the frames in all these houses oh wow
wow that's pretty cool like think about
the faith think about the faith of those
framers is they're building house right
you think sometimes we think like the
little things don't really count or
matter much right like you're building a
house you're framing a house you're
making you know 15 bucks an hour you
know it's like and here you are framing
up this house putting this house
together and yet they had Faith to say
you know what we're gonna go one step
further and we're gonna write the word
of God on these frames because we want
to bless this house in this home and
whoever lives in this house we want to
we want to ask God's word and his
protection to be over these people and
most people aren't going to see the
inside of the walls unless something
like this happens you know what I mean
like that's pretty that's pretty amazing
right and could it be could it be that
that why there was no deaths in this
neighborhood
was because framers took the moment and
the time to say you know what God we're
going to ask for your extra blessing
here in these houses yeah yeah and God
said my name is my name is over this
house yeah like the devil can't have any
of these people in this neighborhood
because my name is literally one of
these houses there's power in the word
the word I mean if you think about you
know God
um bringing into existence the universe
because of a word Jesus stood up middle
of the storm peace be still it says in
the Bible immediately immediately yeah
it uses the word immediately the storm
just went away like this because God
spoke it it happened so God's word these
words that are in this book actually
have power because they were spoken yeah
through God's prophets and through God's
writers but it's God's words to humanity
and that's why we feel so powerful uh
I'm gonna do a little plug for you guys
about our t-shirts uh you know lightwear
dots right shop look up our t-shirts we
have done a an incredible amount of work
wanting to illustrate different Bible
texts and and and different things that
um that's what we're doing we're putting
God's stamp on us and saying we want
your protection God we're your children
and we believe in your word and I I love
wearing Bible verses all over my chest
and everything all the time absolutely
yeah you know it's always humbling you
know when we recognize the part that we
have to play
is is really
like the seeds are already there
the Harvest is God's we just have a part
to play whether we're water and seeds or
plant seeds you know that's all it is
like so so when you connect the
homeowner the people that are in the
home and and they're like hey have you
seen the Bible verses that are in this
house and they show us this destruction
of the Bible verses it's like
that powerful moment where you say you
know you know why you survived this year
baby you know like they haven't
connected us too together right they're
just like that's odd there's Bible
verses is my attic yeah you know you're
like you know why you survived this
event right because God cares for you
and he has a purpose and a plan for you
and this is the roadmap is where we're
headed in the Continuum of time like
Jesus is about to come so we should
understand a few things here yeah about
his character who he is yeah what he
desires for us to do in these final
moments in Earth's history and that that
right there is just it's unreal like
like to be able to connect people with
that
um in the storm middle storm so you know
this is kind of this is our whole
Ministry you know like we're showing you
here a little video of some training we
did for some young people in California
a whole literature evangelism team we
actually trained them in swiftwater
rescue and this is so fun you know like
like that's the other things is that you
have a lot of fun when you're working
for God a lot of young people don't
understand that like like you know I
didn't understand that when I was young
I was like man working for God is going
to be boring and yet we have done things
gone places participated things I would
have never dreamed I could have ever
done on my own and yet it's because of
God's word and the power of his word and
that he's he's the Creator he knows what
makes you tick so he's not going to give
you a dull Journey that's right right
he's going to give you the most amazing
journey there ever is yeah because
you're into an adventure sign up for God
yeah yeah he's created you you know and
and honestly you know on that note this
this is why movies and media and video
games
are so damaging yeah they rob the image
of these opportunities that you could be
out blessing other people I mean you
just you just sit down if you watch a
lot of movies I mean we're talking the
average person watches four to five
hours a day of media projects plays
probably that same amount with video
games and whatnot like they add all that
up what could you have done where could
you have gone
what what you know rescue operations
could you've gone on to save Humanity
you know it's like yeah right and that's
the amazing thing is like we serve a god
who's the god of romance right like has
got is God a hopeless romantic yes he
reads his word you see all the stories
where he's put people together you know
it's like God is the author of romance
and so you know the the romance movies
that are out there don't even come close
to who God is or what he does you know
right and and same thing with Adventure
you know like do you think do you think
God has you know everything lined out
like I always laugh about it you know
because he has such a great sense of
humor too you know it's like when we go
on these trips and these missions it's
like being MacGyver himself right you
know MacGyver was totally fake right
yeah but but at the same time like that
whole just like I'm gonna put some paper
clips together and some bubble gum and
it's gonna work you know and it's like
and this is what God does time and time
again where it's like he shows up and
and he and he achieves The Impossible
and when you put your trust in him your
faith in him your confidence in him man
he gives you even the desires of your
heart it's like we've we've ridden on
Multi millions of dollars worth of
aircraft like like kingpins man you know
like full on like
I'm always pinched to myself when like
we're getting extracted out of a country
and we're sitting in some like super
rich fancy Lear jet you know and it's
like I don't I don't make this money you
know this isn't me you know but like
when God dictates that it's necessary
for his mission like he'll send the
fiery Chariot to pick you up that's
right you know it's like Elijah gotta
direct a route to heaven in a fiery
Chariot and this we we miss this about
God and when we're so involved in
saturated media it robs us of of the
absolute incredible potential that God
sees for us and wants to achieve for us
because now we're just passively you
know gorked out watching yeah it
happened on a screen and then and then
it it it sells us on a lie that only
those exciting amazing romantic stories
comedies you know you name it fake
Hollywood that only happens in the
movies yeah and it's like that's not
true yeah it happens in real life like
why is it that God doesn't work for us
today
and the answer is pretty simple Jesus
says this he says when the son of man
comes again
will he find faith on the earth yeah he
says you will do greater things than
what you've witnessed when Jesus was
speaking to the disciples and you know
yeah that's pretty amazing I mean people
were raised from the dead
yes it's amazing
um you know just in in thinking about
this and closing you know in Matthew 24
there's this verse that says but he that
shall endure to the end the same shall
be saved what's amazing is is that word
endure is is just absolutely pregnant
with meaning it means to to abide to
remain
to not recede or to flee to like hold
your ground stand firm right to
persevere under misfortunes and trials
and to hold fast to one's faith in
Christ to Bear bravely and calmly even
ill treatment well
and so
I believe God is trying to teach us and
this is what we've learned in disaster
responses that God has been teaching us
what does it mean to endure hmm
what does it mean to have courage in the
face of absolute impossibility what does
it mean to abide in Christ and to hang
on to one's Faith to not let that go
and even if you're even if you're
ill-treated because you got to remember
in Matthew 24 if you want to know
exactly where we are on the Continuum of
time
the Bible tells us
Wars rumors rumors of wars pestilence
earthquakes diverse places these things
are happening on a large scale all
around us right now right what it says
next is that there will be many who will
claim to be Christ and we're going to
see false Christ pop up everywhere we're
going to say I'm the Messiah you know be
be wary that you're not deceived this is
what the Bible tells us but even after
that it says the very next thing is that
you will be persecuted and hated for my
namesake so
I look across the landscape and yes is
their persecution there are there's
persecution isolated spots especially in
other countries and things but on the
large scale especially here in the
United States do we see persecution we
haven't even seen anything so how do we
abide how do we endure how do we hang on
to that faith and and as much as
disasters are awful God is giving us a
chance
to know what it means to trust him when
everything falls apart amen and that's
and that's the mission we're on you know
it's like how can we train young people
how can we train Families how do we
train individuals who will have that
experience with God where they're going
to trust God no matter what yeah no
matter what happens you know
and they're going to endure yeah and
that's what you get a chance to see on
these you know each one of these
disasters or or things that your
ministry is going on you get a chance to
see when Things Fall Apart
here here's the Hope here's where here's
where you need to place your trust
because this world is not worth it what
what is coming we can't even begin to
describe it the Bible says that no words
can even articulate what this amazing
world that God is going to place Us in
after this mess right we need to put our
trust in him amen amen Brock you have a
uh promo I want to show for Gideon
rescue
um if you guys are interested at all I
mean literally you want to go and
experience one of these trips or you
have a burden to serve God you don't
know how or even in what way or whatever
like that please get in touch with Brock
uh he needs help uh you know it is so
true the the the fields are plentiful
and the labors are few and we need your
help to go out there and bless other
people and and we see these disasters
starting to pop up more frequently so
watch this trailer if you guys like it
we'll put a link to the description of
his in the link in the description for
his ministry please get in touch with
him
um but yeah man thanks for sharing Brock
man thank you for having me
this world's fast falling apart
we're seeing disaster in every hand
Heavenly Father please help us this was
the only way out for some who found they
were surrounded by surging torrents
and the window of avoiding catastrophic
outcomes is closing
and one of the biggest lessons that
we've learned in Disaster Response has
been what's most important to God
what's on his heart
what's on his mind
and the answer is simple because God
cares for people
cares for you he cares for me
and he cares for all other people every
nation every Kindred every tongue every
tribe around this globe
especially when people find themselves
in their Darkest Days
these wonderful people showed up on my
door
to help with the storm damage
they heard a story of my wife Jane and
I's losing our son July 30th to Suicide
that's our Second Son in three years
I don't know what I'd do without them
because I know I can get this done
myself
and
this world's not all bad
how do we reach people in their greatest
hour of need
and to accomplish this goal
it's been amazing
God has never disappointed us he has
poured out every resource he has pulled
every stop he has given us every
opportunity to reach people
of the essence why because time is
running out and when people are facing
some of the worst disasters in their
lives they ask all the right questions
why are we here where are we going what
does this mean is the end of all things
at hand we need much much more material
everybody's so open and receptive and
they want books they're asking like give
us mortgages more I think we need a
thousand times more of the resource and
literature yeah there's so many people
out here so what does God need
in this hour of Earth's history
he needs you
it needs me
needs hands
who will go for me whom shall I send who
will be my Representatives
when the earth is growing dark
who will let their light shine before
men so that we can glorify God in heaven
[Music]
[Applause]
there's no mistake
Jesus is coming soon
we don't have much time
and so from our trainings
to our responses
to the opportunities that God gives us
this is the mission
and this is the mission that we invite
you on even as the Gideon rescue company
join us we need your prayers but most
importantly we need your hands who will
go for God
when the world is fast failing
who will be there to be his Rescuers
who will be there to really Reach people
in their greatest hour of need
[Music]
foreign
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you